i need to get glasses with pads on them
these guys slip down every time i have
to use my hand
so
those are expensive
[Music]
peace awards is back and i'm ready
what you guys got for me today
nicole i love that energy but today
we're taking on something very
challenging pineapple pizza
oh my gosh oh my gosh you guys are
trying to kill me
and if you get me and frank to eat
pineapple pizza then you're definitely a
master chef all right all right i will
give it a shot but who am i going up
against today so today nicole you're
going up against a familiar face andrew
ray aka binging with bad [ __ ] oh my
gosh babish he's the best but you know
babish
i'm coming for you binging with bad
[ __ ] in the building hey nicole
andrew thank you for being here thank
you for having me so today is all about
pineapple on pizza
see that's what's gonna ask you why do
you think it's so controversial well i
have a few theories on that it's because
it's gross uh it's disgusting it's
gnarly it's ugly uh and i don't like it
that being said i'm a strict libertarian
about pizza toppings whatever you put on
your pizza is your business and i will
fight to the death for your right to do
it and so in my mind because i don't
like pineapple on pizza the only way to
make pineapple on pizza work was to make
a pizza that isn't really pizza
what makes it not pizza what do you mean
well it's more of a taco it is an al
pastor pork pizza pork that i'm going to
shove in the shape of a taco so i'm
going to start doing this thing so i
have my al pastor pork here j kenji
lopez all came up with a way to make al
pastor pork at home which is to marinate
the pork the way you would there's dried
guajillo chilies in there and ancho
chiles and instead of putting it onto a
skewer and roasting it like like a spit
you put it into a loaf pan and then you
put bacon on top and just braise it
basically all right so there's my al
pastor pork yes uh and now all i gotta
do is uh make it into a pizza i'm doing
the mark iacono method which is to roll
it out oh it's fighting me oh look at
this look at all the bubs though you
hear that the little parts that's called
fermentation baby i need to get glasses
with pads on them these guys slip down
every time i have to use my hand
so
those are expensive i've got my pizza
dough stretched out yes looking good
saved a little bit of that uh that pork
marinade oh wow use that as my base face
sauce just enough to remind you that
it's technically a pizza
now i'm going to lay down my oaxaca
cheese
cheese like a cheese being the mexican
string cheese that i love more than any
other cheese question mark and then i've
got
my
al pastor pork i almost forgot the most
important ingredient pineapple goes down
i am quite a fan of pineapple not on
pizza okay al pastor which is what this
is yes
my pizza's all dressed up i'm gonna
throw this in give it some
blast and heat and as i always say
whenever i put something in the oven
let's see what happens
wow look at there we go
and that looks good is my al pastor
pizza you know some fresh chopped onions
then lastly of course
the devil's lettuce this is just for you
and just for the sake of
authenticity i was about to say
al pastor pizza
authenticity dick
[ __ ]
dummy
that was too much handy too much do you
want to try this of course all right
let's see how it turned out you might
have noticed i didn't slice the pizza
well let me tell you why i didn't slice
the pizza because there's only one way
to eat an al pastor taco pizza it's a
taco pizza
all right oh
this is brilliant
nicole yes the challenge was to put
pineapple on pizza how do you think i
did i think you knocked it out the park
first of all this is ingenious i've
never eaten a pizza like this but i
think that this is the way to go
secondly i love the chilies the
pineapple the hot the savory the sweet
and i love cilantro and onions so to me
this is a win i think that it works i
think that uh the alpac store because
it's somebody else's recipe turned out
really well the taco is a little more
problematic than i thought because
there's a layer of very thick bread on
the outside the up to get through it
tastes pretty good and i'm happy with it
yeah you should be delicious well done
well i'm excited to see what you do all
right let's see i'm gonna give it a shot
either way we're getting paid
andrew are you ready to try what i'm
gonna make today i'm not ready but i'm
willing because people are so opposed to
pineapple on pizza i decide to try
something a little different i'm making
philly cheesesteak pineapple pizza how
you like that that sounds really good
yeah you want to try it i really do okay
let's get started okay so step one i
have this thinly sliced beautiful rib
eye so i'm just gonna put a little olive
oil
put a little butter for flavor
oh and it's sizzling and it's sizzling
hot just the way steak likes it this
might be the first philly cheesesteaks
it's being made with butter and that's
right that's really good that's right
we're going to put some butter this is
the last dragon pizza way
chop it up
yeah i'm just going to put some
mushrooms in here pretty smart
and
some of my pickled pineapples in here
i'm gonna chop it up again so some of
this pineapple juice
can get in the meat this is a winner all
around it sounds like it's gonna taste
better it's clearly easier to make yeah
and you're making it instead of me so
it's going to whip now that it's off the
fire i'm gonna put in some green bell
peppers and you know i'm the type of
person in my philly cheese steak
i really love a shark provolone i like
the whiz
yeah i'm a whiz guy okay so now i'm just
gonna put some sauce on here
and get it nice all over all right so
you got provolone in the meat now what's
this mutts okay this is mozzarella
because you know after all it's pizza it
is pizza so we need some mozzarella so i
put caramelized onions as the base on
top of the cheese on my pie now i'm
putting my philly cheesesteak with
pineapple on my pizza it looks delicious
and then i'm going to add some extra
provolone cheese because
why
no
this is the most cheese that any pizza
has ever had i'll be mad but you know
what this is how i like it i'm gonna put
this in the oven
500 degrees or higher
and let's see what this bad boy comes
out like
okay i think it's done let's see how i
did let's see this thing
it's looking beautiful oh my god
oh
wow
that's what you think about that
that is
beautiful
it's hot as hell i can't feel the roof
of my mouth but
that is
really really good what the bottom she
got on that
look at what she accomplished
a little more than a home oven and some
know-how
wow you like it it's amazing thank you
it's really really good
i'm pleased i probably got to render
that fat off a little bit
but the pineapple is the bomb oh my god
really plays nice with the philly
cheesesteak the the pop of the pineapple
i think that pineapple belongs on this
pizza it tastes delicious
it's wonderful
my solution to this problem was to not
make a pizza
and yours was to make it work on a pizza
i'm rooting for you honestly that's uh
that you know i'm hoping you will well
i'm hoping you win well
we'll be right back after these messages
well it's not up to me
and it's not up to you we got frank and
josephine here today they're gonna judge
so let's see what they think let's do it
[Applause]
all right joe here's our first pie it's
a philly cheesesteak pizza with pickled
pineapple it looks like it's going to
have a beautiful pulp
yeah right you see all that melted
cheese in the middle
i don't know pineapples it's a beautiful
thing but it's not my thing maybe you
can win me over with this pizza let's
see
wow
interesting
crust is really yummy oh this cheese is
fantastic i think i'm gonna take this
one home you like it
i love it i'm actually really enjoying
the pineapple which is really weird i
don't think i would ever said that we
better hope your father's not watching
the pineapple hits hard it's got a lot
of ingredients on it but the pineapple
doesn't get lost in that is this the
first time they eat a pineapple on pizza
it is for me i never even
dared to try it everybody's looking
above and they're just watching me i'm
i'm getting nervous my ears are burning
it's not something that i usually
attempt or i even think about putting on
pizza i feel like i would be crucified
by uh ancestors past if they walked into
my pizzeria and saw a pineapple on the
pizza this changed my whole
thought on pineapple pizza i'll be
honest with you we got through the first
pizza we didn't burst into flames did
you do the sign of course before you
came in i got to do it i actually did it
i think i'm doing pretty good right now
god's with me all right let's bring in
pie number two
all right all right all right
so what we have here is our taco al
pastor pizza and i'm told we're supposed
to fold it and eat it like a taco
honestly i love tacos as much as i love
pizza and this is actually my favorite
taco so how you doing
[Applause]
jesus christmas oh cow look at this
[Music]
it's hot your hamburger no
you haven't touched the pizza in a long
time buddy
[Applause]
i was taking a lot of work to get them i
taste that roasted pork you got it very
good
[Music]
presentation was great when it came to
the table it looks beautiful the crust
is nice it's a little hard to eat now
it was a little hard to eat i thought
the dough would have been a little
uh crispier but
on a positive note i think the flavors
are really really
tasty i think it's definitely a smart
idea you know like if you're working
with pineapple on pizza to do an alpha
store pizza it makes sense the last one
was definitely different this seems more
like i can wrap my head around it as far
as pineapple is an ingredient i think i
know which one i like better i think we
got to talk this over and then we'll
bring them out all right sounds good
oh
see these still
trying to intimidate us andrew nicole i
really didn't expect this i gotta say i
came in here i thought this pineapple
was gonna kill me but
i didn't expect these two pizzas to be
as good as they were i had so much fun
cooking with andrew likewise but now i
need to know who's the winner and i need
to know right now hold your horses sorry
i'm with joe really the pizzas were both
fantastic that alpa star pizza just just
the presentation of it was beautiful and
on the other hand you have a philly
cheesesteak pizza with pickled
pineapples it was a hard choice
you want to let them know what it was
it was the philly cheesesteak pizza
[Applause]
[Music]
who made it
you guys are
thank you
the functionality on the alpine store
pizza it was a little tough to eat
but the flavor was delicious that roast
pork was banging it was i was eating it
if there's one thing pizza shouldn't be
it's tough to eat don't smoke pot kids
the creativity on your pie nicole was
outstanding the provolone on top just
just made it oh thank you so much i
wanted to try to make it as authentic as
possible and i wanted to annoy philly
italians and new york italians
she's giving us one of these
and then she's still [ __ ] with us
jokes on
i'm starting a new tradition where the
loser has to present
the trophy to the winner that's it you
have to do it on one knee no you do
i accept though i like that thank you so
much i'd love to come back as a judge
any time
it's a lot easier on this side
[Music]
you